[Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  do  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  laughs  [Music]  ugh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Music]  let's go  let's go  [Music]  stuff  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  let's go  [Music]  hey there tom skaper if you're hearing  this and that means you made it to the  end i just want to thank you so much for  viewing it's greatly appreciated make  sure you hit that subscribe button and  make sure you hit that like button  because that will help me out a lot  also you can follow me on instagram and  twitter the links are down in the  description below  and again i just want to say thank you  so much for checking in and i'll see you  next time  [Music]  [Music]  ba  [Music]  uh  oh  [Music]  [Music]  you